so that's what identities are
um i mean it sounds fun to say equal and
identical don't
those aren't they equivalent statements
answer no mathematically they mean
different things okay so let me show you
how you need to set out a proof of an
identity
so let me show you how not to prove this
okay because showing you how not to
prove it
first
we'll give you a bit of instruction on
how to prove it all right
your instinct whenever you see something
like this is that looks like an equation
does it not
this equals this
it's not an equation it's an identity
any value of theta you throw in there it
will be true okay so therefore i mean to
be helpful we should really say this
but all the time you'll see an equal
sign there so you need to be familiar
with the fact that this is not an
equation it's actually an identity even
if it doesn't look like that okay
now here's the thing when you've got an
equation like this right your instinct
is to use that as your first line and
then start working on it right so in
this case you go x squared minus nine
equals zero and then you factorize and
then you read off your two solutions no
problems okay
but if you take the same approach here
you run into trouble or at least
you look like you're into trouble so if
i expand this left hand side okay that's
what i get it's just difference of
squares and then i do
the right hand side
by now you kind of want to be able to
recognize that left hand side right if
you were to replace this one with sine
squared plus cos squared because that's
the pythagorean identity
it would be sine squared plus cos
squared
minus sine squared so all you are left
with is cos squared
okay so at this point you're like sweet
that's true so i'm done
okay except you're not because that's
wrong okay why is this wrong
mathematically i haven't done anything
wrong like i went from here to here and
it's true
i went from here to here also true right
so the logic holding this together is
fine
the problem is i use this
as my starting point right why is it bad
why can't i not use that as a starting
point yeah
it's just you're trying to get that
solution
good yeah um i'm gonna come back to that
do you wanna say something different
right now um you're assuming that the
statement is true good okay and both of
those are saying exactly the same thing
from different sides right so let me say
again in another way
i i started with this right
i can't start with this i'm supposed to
end with this okay so that can't be the
first line it's gonna be the last line
right i've got it completely backwards
which is another way of saying look
you're meant to prove this the burden of
proof is on you it's like walking into a
legal court and you're
the um you're the defense and you're
like well everyone assuming that my
client is innocent and then going on and
concluding all these things it's rubbish
right you can't use that as your basis
okay yes
possibly all right so instead
let me show you how you should send it
out now this is my yes
okay
i've deliberately chosen a very simple
question okay so it won't take me long
and you'll see
mathematically one two three
it's gonna look almost exactly the same
almost exactly it's just a minor subtle
difference in how it's set out okay but
being that it's a proof a proof is an
argument right well the way you set out
an argument really matters
here's the way i do it
i look at these two things there's a
left hand side to this
and there's a right hand side okay now
usually
terms and conditions apply i'll come
back to that in a second usually one
side is much worse and much more
complicated than the other side and most
people's brains work in like we've
practiced at simplifying things not
making them more complicated so you pick
the more complicated side and then you
think about how you can simplify in
order to get to the other one okay and
you can choose doesn't matter which one
you choose so i'm going to choose the
left hand side
okay i'm going to write it out
word for word
character for character
and then i'm going to start working on
it now because it's so simple there's
not really many other places i can go
i'm just going to
expand right i'm gonna go that's cos
squared and now i'm gonna say aha now i
have arrived at what i was supposed to
arrive at the other side
right hand side therefore
it's true
done okay so this
mathematically like it's all the same
okay but the way i've presented the
argument is very different question do
you have to put a conclusion statement
saying it's true or can i just say that
no not really i think once you've gotten
to hear everything that was being
assessed has been assessed i just kind
of said that as a ending rhetorical
flourish but yeah that's that's all you
need to do okay
all right now um wait before i move on
are there any questions about that any
questions
okay now i did say i did say terms and
conditions apply okay one of the reasons
why students around the country really
like this approach right is because
occasionally you'll have a left hand
side
which looks really gross and complicated
so it looks like a nice place to start
and then you have a right hand side
which is equally gross and complicated
and you're like i have no idea how i'm
going to go from there to there and i
have no idea how i'm going to go from
there to there okay so i'm like i'm just
stuck okay so i don't know which side to
start from or i can start on one side
and get somewhere
i simplify as far down as i can and then
i hit a brick wall i just don't know
what identity i should use i know like
15 of them and i just don't know how to
combine them okay so if you get this
situation here's what i encourage you to
do
um because it comes out quite a lot
particularly if you are fortunate enough
to get a trigger identity question at
the end of your paper and it's one of
these twisty ones worth three or four
marks okay you're gonna have this right
proof
left hand side equals right hand side
okay and they're both gonna look really
gross okay
in this case what i would do is i would
start left hand side equals and simplify
it as much as you possibly can you will
get down to some point like you should
be able to do something with it when
you're like okay i've stopped i've got a
um you know i can't go any further
i don't know what else to do and i'm
running out of time what are my other
options okay
at this point over on the right hand
side of your page
see what i did there on the right hand
side of your page look at the other side
okay
and start to work on it if this identity
is true
then if you simplify this as far as you
possibly can and you simplify this as
far as you possibly can often you end up
at the same thing right on both sides
here okay now that's not the proof
you're not finished
you then have to take what you've gotten
to over here suppose you end up with
something like oh i don't know
suppose it's really really complicated
but all you end up with is a sine square
okay and then over here you end up with
a sine squared okay
then what you need to do is take these
steps over here and just write them
in reverse
because that will take you sure enough
one two
three four whatever number of lines to
the right hand side because that's where
you came from right
so again it's it's doing this kind of
thing but it's applying the logic to
both sides independently okay that's the
way i would recommend if you really hit
up against the brick wall and you don't
know what to do okay